Thera nose began as a startup of almost
mythical proportions and goals in 2003
it's just an incredible morality tale a
woman once hailed as a Silicon Valley
visionary is facing federal fraud
charges tonight
Athena's founder Elizabeth Holmes has
now officially been indicted on federal
wire fraud charges the US Attorney's
Office accusing her of indeed imagine
building a company that everyone thought
would change the world but ended up
being one of the biggest frauds in
history Thera knows the company started
in 2003 by Stanford dropout Elizabeth
Holmes was just that they fooled
everyone receiving over six hundred
million dollars of funding in the
process what farah naaz promised was a
revolutionary blood analyzer that could
run hundreds of tests just from a finger
prick in the comfort of your own home
however this story isn't one of great
success or inspiration this story is
about deceit fraud manipulation and a
CEO who would stop at nothing to get her
goal this is the story of thoroughness a
company once worth nine billion dollars
and the story of how it all came
crashing down in one of the worst
disasters in Silicon Valley history what
exactly was Thoreau knows and how did it
go so horribly wrong
[Music]
Elizabeth Holmes was born to a
well-connected family with a rich
history from a young age Elizabeth knew
what she wanted in life to be a
billionaire at age 18 she went on a
Stanford run tour of China where she met
a man 20 years her senior called sunny
sunny immigrated from Pakistan and had
some success in the.com boom of 1999
pocketing 40 million dollars in the
process he had what she wanted money and
the status of a successful entrepreneur
sunny would later play a big role in
Elizabeth's company during another trip
to Asia
Elizabeth witnessed the SARS outbreak
from that point she came home determined
to change the world upon returning home
she didn't leave her room for five days
and slept two hours and night while
working on a patent idea the idea was to
create a wearable patch which could
continually test the blood of the wearer
and admit the right dose of medicine in
real time filtered determination she
dropped out of Stanford at age 19 and
started her own company the early days
were not glamorous the office of the new
company was in a part of town known for
shootings one day while in her car
Elizabeth was shot at with the bullet
just narrowly missing her despite this
she received a 1 million dollar seed
investment from her old neighbor who had
made some money investing in hotmail
early on Elizabeth wrote on the
reputation of her investors however when
it came to investors that specialized in
medicine she struggled to convince them
as a lack of knowledge started showing
it wasn't a surprise because she had
only spent a few semesters at university
so for most tech entrepreneurs this kind
of thing isn't a big issue for example
Mark Zuckerberg only needed to master
coding as a child and he could have
struck it big with little university
knowledge on the other hand medicine and
chemistry are fields that require
decades of knowledge and research to
find a breakthrough
regardless by the end of the year
Elizabeth had nearly 6 million dollars
in funding and her idea had changed now
the blood testing would be done by a
cartridge and reader system he is how it
was supposed to work patients would
prick their fingers storing blood in a
small cartridge pushing this cartridge
into a machine would run the tests the
fairness machines envisioned would
perform tests on the spot and beam
information via the internet to a lab
where personnel would interpret the
results and send a report back
traditionally the current industry
procedure was to draw a syringe full of
blood from a vein and physically send
the sample to a lab the old way use
large machines the size of several
business photo copiers and the results
will take a few days to get back from a
doctor
Thera nos would try to scout down the
components of these massive machines to
fit into a box the size of a personal
computer thoroughness was going to make
this process faster more comfortable and
completely bypass the need for a doctor
in this particular medical field there
are many components that are used to
test blood each of which performs a
different type of test for example one
test shoots a beam of light into the
sample blood and measures the light
reflected while other tests require
chemical reactions now this is the big
liar and the problem with fairness there
were several issues that made the
thoroughness machine is nearly
impossible firstly the components would
interfere with each other when placed in
close proximity due to a magnitude of
problems including heat light and
electrical activity next to have
sufficient volume of test samples from
only a pinprick on a finger the drops of
blood had to be diluted over diluted
samples gave inaccurate results and was
outside the detection capability of the
hardware so in short for the technology
to be possible fairness had to make
major breakthroughs on all fronts of
blood analysis they had to do all of
this while only reporting to Elizabeth
who didn't really have the knowledge
skipping forward to 2006 thier
anastomosis era nurse 1.0 Elizabeth
enlisted engineers to design a new
version called the Edison however no
fairness machine would ever be accurate
or capable of performing the full range
of tests that Elizabeth claimed
Elizabeth started to push the
engineering team manager to make the
Edison development around 24/7 when the
manager refused stating that the
engineers were overworked as it is
Elizabeth hired a parallel engineering
team and pitted the two teams against
each other in a survival of the fittest
race this kind of thing was actually a
tactic that Steve Jobs also used with
the original Mac in the iPhone but in
fairness his case the losing team would
be fired Elizabeth also started doing
some ethically questionable things such
as running a pilot test on cancer
patients with the company Pfizer she
knew the product didn't work yet but
insisted on running real tests on people
that had serious illnesses to highlight
how serious this was blood tests are
usually used to increase or decrease a
patient's dosage of medication or
diagnose conditions which may require
immediate action doctors his lab results
today 70% of their decisions on if the
results are false it could be fatal
of course the only reason the cancer
trials went ahead is that Elizabeth had
been outright lying to investors and
clients up about how well the product
actually worked the same year the
company's CFO discovered that Elizabeth
had been lying he told it a stop instead
of agreeing she fired him on the spot
after this Elizabeth never hired another
chief financial officer again leaving
the position vacant for a decade in 2007
there was no biggest Silicon Valley
stars and Steve Jobs Elizabeth has
started developing an obsession for jobs
an employee even found a newspaper cut
out on a desk where someone called her
the next Steve Jobs the obsession
bordered on insanity for example after
she found out that Steve scheduled
marketing meetings on Wednesdays she
would do the same with the same
marketing firm that Steve used she would
even recruit a few Apple employees one
of this included one of Steve Jobs as
oldest friends and the former senior
vice president of software at Apple av2
vania he even went out of retirement to
join the Fairness board the board of
fairness was made up of a star-studded
panel Don Lucas who mentored the founder
of Oracle was the chairman one day
Elizabeth once it's a restructure the
company shares which would give her
majority voting rights X Apple employee
AV who was on the board didn't think
that this was a good idea and paired
with the information that he'd received
from employees about the problems during
testing he felt like he had to do
something he spoke with Don Lucas the
chairman but this resulted in AV
resigning after he felt that his advice
fell on deaf ears Elizabeth had the
board wrapped around her finger she was
a master manipulator she spoke in a low
baritone voice in order to be taken more
seriously the question was as a
nineteen-year-old how do you go about
the process of convincing people that
you know what you're doing
it's about finding people who believe in
you because the worst possible thing in
the world is to have someone who doesn't
believe in you backing you because it's
not going to result in a good situation
on occasion she forgot to put on the
voice and was caught using a natural
voice before realizing and dropping
several tones
has it well if I use traditional words
to describe what we're doing it's hard
because people then associate it with
conventional processes for an alleged
drug shortly after the company moved to
a prime location in Silicon Valley a new
member of the sales team soon found out
that the financial projections were
based off pilot tests that weren't
honest the issue was brought to the
board who ran an emergency meeting and
decided to fire Elizabeth two hours
after they brought her in to tell her
the decision she had convinced them to
reverse it this incredible power of
persuasion is another reason why
fairness went so far with no real
working technology shortly after the
meeting Elizabeth fired those who raised
the alarm by this stage employees
leaving or being fired was common in
fact all employees who came from Apple
would leave in just a couple of years
around this time an old family friend
Richard foolís created a patent for a
method of transmitting information from
blood testing machines to doctors he did
this out of eventual spite for not being
asked advice when Elizabeth started the
company in his field of expertise he was
a doctor he sold his medical
demonstration video company for 50
million dollars in a few years time
Richard will go to court with fairness
over the patent he made which in private
he called the thoroughness killer
Richards patents wouldn't go on to kill
fairness but his actions would by 2009
Sonny the millionaire Pakistani
immigrant was now Elizabeth's boyfriend
and had joined the company as second in
charge sunny came from a software
background and had little knowledge of
the inner workings of a medical company
he claimed to have written 10 million
lines of code while at Microsoft but the
average developer at Microsoft only
writes a thousand lines a year he also
boasted of having extreme wealth and
only coming to work because he wanted to
he also had a habit of latching on to
buzzwords and using them despite little
knowledge of the topic engineers would
use terms out of context to see if we'd
continue to use them he did but Sonny
knew how to control people he was feared
within the company he constantly fired
people and let his tempers flare 2010
saw a whole lot of money pouring into
Silicon Valley Facebook Twitter and Eber
were all taking off
meanwhile Walgreens and Safeway had both
entered talks with farah naaz to partner
and create wellness centers these were
sections in their stores where patients
could get blood tests Theron Oz
presented Walgreens with a hundred and
ninety two different tests that could be
performed by their Edison machine
however only about half of them were
even theoretically possible the only
proof that the technology worked was a
review from John Hopkins Medical School
the document was only two pages long and
summarized a meeting where therenear
showed the university representatives
some data results no actual testing was
done on the machines themselves but
thoroughness was hot stuff and walgreens
had the fear of missing out and letting
their competitors land a partnership
Elizabeth also made such an impression
on the Walgreens and Safeway executives
that they trusted every word she said
combined Safeway and Walgreens gave
theranos a hundred and five million
dollars in investment in loans around
this time Elizabeth realized that the
Edison wasn't good enough so she
commissioned the mini lab the third
iteration of the blood testing product
meanwhile sunny intimidated employees
and watched CCTV footage of them to see
exactly how long people were working one
time he told an employee that he would
quote fix him after finding that he'd
only worked eight hours per day
Elizabeth backed up the decision stating
two employees that quote if anyone here
believes that you are not working on the
best thing humans have ever built or if
you're cynical then you should leave end
quote
basically anyone who agreed with
Elizabeth got promoted and those who
doubted got fired
by 2012 Safeway wasn't doing well they
had poured 350 million dollars into
renovations as store space across their
store locations in anticipation for the
thoroughness machines they were only met
with constant launch delays and excuses
when fairness did start accepting
Safeway employee samples they were
tested on existing commercial
third-party machines in a lab but
Safeway was lied to and given the
impression that all of these tests were
being performed on fairness Edison
machines they weren't even running most
of the tests on the fairness devices and
most the tests are being run on
third-party machines did miss Holmes
know at the time that fair nose could
not do all those tests yes
meanwhile fairness is lawsuit from
Richard the jealous family friend and
medical doctor was in full swing
he was serious about taking fairness
down he hired the same lawyer that
worked on the deposition case of Bill
Gates and the cost $1,000 now a pivotal
point for fairness is downfall came with
the subpoena of Ian Gibbons who had led
the chemistry team since 2005 in May of
2013
Ian was notified by fairness that in
just two days time he would be involved
in Richards trial he feared that
anything that he might say may put the
company in jeopardy and exposed the
liars Ian was miserable of fairness and
had just been demoted but feared that
leaving as a 67 year old would make it
impossible for him to get another job
the next morning Ian's wife Rochelle
found him in the bathroom having
overdosed on medication he died a week
later in hospital
Beckett theranos in a display of the
coldest heart Elizabeth didn't return
Rachelle's call about the death of her
husband elizabeth informed only a small
number of employees about Ian's passing
and loosely mentioned hosting a service
this was never carried out she seemed to
have just brushed off Ian's death pretty
casually after spending two million
dollars in the case Richard settled in a
massive blow to his pride this would
fuel the fire in Richard that would
eventually bring down fairness during
this period theranos was still carrying
out tests on third-party machines and
desperately trying to get results
this included stacking six mini labs on
top of each other to get
high throughput of tests the additional
heat generated actually hindered the
accuracy of tests further but their nose
didn't have time to work on their
technology they had already promised
their machines to the world and they had
a 140 million dollar contract with
walgreens which required them to launch
by February 2013 and there were four
months overdue the lies continued the
financial forecasts that Sonny gave to
investors were 10 times higher than the
internal forecasts of the company these
numbers were completely fabricated as
Theron operated without a CFO for the
last seven years ever since he was fired
ther enosis board as always were still
stacked with high-profile reputable
names so no one doubted the company this
included former US Secretary of State
Henry Kissinger former director of the
US Office of Management and Budget
George Shultz and future Secretary of
Defense
Jim Mad Dog matters had all joined the
board the company was very politically
connected by the stage
Elizabeth even through Hillary Clinton
the fundraiser for her 2016 campaign
money just kept pouring in partner fun
to put ninety four million dollars in
shares Rupert Murdoch chipped in 125
million the Walmart brothers put in 150
million the DeVos family put in another
hundred million
this gave theranos a nine billion dollar
valuation and Elizabeth was worth five
billion dollars one the shortcomings of
the technology were well known within
the company but employees were usually
too scared to do anything fearing
retaliation from sunny Elizabeth or the
company's lawyers employees were forced
to sign confidentiality agreements when
they started and again when they left
this stopped a lot of people from taking
action
Tylar shorts grant another board member
George Shultz was in a more privileged
position he noticed the issues of
thoroughness and after falling on Sonny
and Elizabeth's deaf ears he quit he
tried to talk to his grandfather he told
George about the Edison's inaccuracy and
the constant failing of quality control
tests he told him about how fairness had
doomed everyone by testing samples on
existing third-party commercial machines
not fairness his own Edison machines
incredibly Elizabeth had put such a
spell on George Shultz that he would
disregard everything his grandson Tyler
told him in mid-2014
fortune magazine released a front page
story titled this CEO is out for blood
this Rockets Elizabeth - celebrity
status and from this point she is
constantly making media appearances
Forbes USA Today NPR Fox Business CNBC
CNN and CBS News all took their turn to
cover the success story of the youngest
ever self-made female billionaire Barack
Obama made Elizabeth the US ambassador
for global entrepreneurship and she was
added to the board of fellows at Harvard
Medical School
Elizabeth enjoyed the fame she grew her
security team 220 her office was
redesigned to look like the president's
Oval Office complete wood bulletproof
glass
Elizabeth spoken a TED talk about her
idea to change the world
she said soon no one would have to say
goodbye too soon and went on to tell the
audience of a heartfelt story about how
her uncle had passed away from cancer
but of course the TED talk was merely an
act in reality she wasn't even close to
her uncle and had just exploited his
death for her narrative meanwhile cracks
were beginning to crumble the Empire
Richard by this stage had created a gang
of fairness skeptics including Ian's
Widow
Rochelle they collected information and
then took it to John Kerry we at The
Wall Street Journal as John began
investigating countless sources and
former employees came out of the
woodwork
they anonymously provided information
about the story Thera nose attacked
everyone who was talking they used their
pile of money and they threatened to sue
everyone else he spoke to the Wall
Street Journal they even hired private
investigators to stalk anyone they
suspected
several letters were sent to the Wall
Street Journal to try and kill the story
threatening defamation lawsuits Rupert
Murdoch the owner of The Wall Street
Journal and investor and thoroughness
was asked by Elizabeth to personally
kill the story he refused stating that
he had confidence in the editors to
handle the truth whatever it may be the
reaction from thoroughness was intense
and the story wasn't even out yet
business that usual continued at
fairness Elizabeth was making Whitehouse
appearances often then but under the
veneer the machines could still only do
a small number of tests and where
inaccurate would even just those
thoroughness
continue to demonstrate the minilab VIP
guests they pricked their finger then
waited until they left and then went on
to use existing commercial third-party
lab machines to return the results Vice
President Joe Biden even paid Theron
also visit he was shown a fake lab that
was set up just for the visit he was
impressed saying that there was the lab
of the future and praised fairness the
dark truth about fairness was finally
unveiled in The Wall Street Journal
article of October 15th 2015 it was a
bombshell all the major news articles
picked it up people began questioning
thoroughness and its secrecy Elizabeth
took it olena stride not shying away
from the questions but instead outright
lying to the public it appeared that she
thought everyone would just believe her
again but this time it was different
now people were asking serious questions
[Music]
and just this morning The Wall Street
Journal ran a pretty scathing article
about the company legend if the
company's proprietary testing devices
may be inaccurate and basically accusing
thoroughness of deceptive practices to
Elizabeth Holmes the founder and CEO of
Thoreau knows give her a chance to
answer the charges raised in the article
this home was welcomed back to me of
money it's great to be here thank you
what do you think's going on here this
is what happens when you work to change
things and first they think you're crazy
then they fight you and then all of a
sudden you change the world and I have
to say I
I personally was shocked to see that the
journal would publish something like
this just as the story had been
published the FDA made a surprise
inspection of thier nose in further
investigations it was found that the
fairness edison blood testing machine
only performed 12 out of 250 tests and
even those produced wildly erratic
results now Thera nose was in full
damage control Elizabeth broke up with
Sonny and fired him a criminal
investigation was underway and a probe
by the Securities and Exchange
Commission was also proceeding the
investors began suing theranos one by
one partner fund sued for a hundred
million Walgreens for a hundred and
forty million Elizabeth had to close the
trial out and had to pay four point five
million dollars to Arizona State where
most patients had received testing
thoroughness had voided nearly a million
lab results ten patients would sue
fairness for medical battery but
shockingly amongst all of this Elizabeth
never apologized it seemed to her mealy
mistake along the way which could be
fixed so Elizabeth and Sonny both knew
what they were doing
lying to investors their clients the
regulator's patients and even their own
board no one outside can be blamed for
not realizing the fraud ahead of time
even the board made up of seasoned
professionals was masterfully
manipulated into giving Elizabeth ninety
nine point seven percent of the voting
rights
she seemed by all accounts a sociopath
willing to stop at nothing to make her
company a success not caring who or what
got in her way
and who knows how far the lie could have
gone she continued with all smiles and
even after the truth came out
Elizabeth's actions could be a microcosm
a case for a modern problem in society
whether need to be successful or at
least appear successful outweighs
everything else there's possibly another
fault at play here a Fault in the human
condition it's the illusionary effect
where if you repeat a lie enough times
people start to believe it especially if
you have credible names surrounding the
product the SEC settled with Elizabeth
Holmes in March of 2018
she lost voting control had to give away
her portion of the stock and was banned
from being an officer a director of any
public company for ten years sunny still
hasn't reached a settlement with the SEC
both Sonny and Elizabeth have been
indicted on criminal charges in an
ongoing lawsuit at the time of this
video
they are both pleaded not guilty and
each faced 20 years in prison
Thera nose was dissolved in September
2018 so one question remains if fairness
was to keep going would they have made
it with their blood testing machinery
ever have worked well actually it's a
harder question to answer than one might
think when they were running out of
money they tested on real patients as a
proof of concept to gain more funding
which is of course what brought them
down in the first place but say they did
get funding without testing on patients
the unveiled mini lab was only
incrementally better than the Edison
machine
even though fairness had hundreds of
millions of dollars at their disposal so
if that being said is pretty unlikely
that any company would have succeeded in
this so that wraps up our look at
fairness so I know that would have lost
some of the faith and humanity that you
had but if you want to see some real
actual breakthroughs and research in the
medical field the things such as
real-life nanobots being used in cancer
with with success in mice trials or stem
cells being injected directly into the
brains of stroke victims allowing for
recovery has never seen before and even
enabling a wheelchair-bound man to walk
again this is the kind of cool stuff
that gets lost in the sea of media day
to day but you can find those videos
right here on ColdFusion I'll leave a
link in the description below anyway
thanks for watching this has been - go
go you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll see you again soon for the next
video
Shia's guys have a good one
[Music]
you
[Music]